اعلان وقفتنا الثانيه مع مراسلتنا في
الاردن سها جميل وعن ارتفاع اسعار السجائر
في الاردن ماذا لديك يا سهى الناس 90%
بدخنوا يمكن
نسبه التدخين عاليه جدا في الاردن صباح
الخير عادل صباح الخير راويه من المعروف
ان الشعب الاردني يعني حسب دراسات عالميه
هو يعني اعلى معدلات انتشار للتدخين 88%
من الذكور في الاردن هم مدخنين بالتالي
يعني قبل ايام قامت بعض شركات الدخان او
الطبخ برفع اسعار الدخان ما بين خمسه قروش
الى خمسه عشر قرشا الضريبه الحكومه لم
تعمل على رفع الضريبه على الدخان ولكن
الشركات من نفسها قامت برفع اسعار الدخان
ما ادى الى يعني قصه جدليه بين الحكومه
وشركات التدخين وحتى المواطنين يعني
المواطنين في سؤالنا بالشارع لن يمتنعوا
عن التدخين لن يتوقفوا عن التدخين سيلجاون
الى السجائر الالكترونيه سيلجاون الى
الاراجيل ولكن ارتفاع اسعار السجائر يسوع
كانت على السجائر التقليديه وليس على
السجائر الالكترونيه يعني فبدهم يذهبوا
لبديل اخر
نعم
نعم يلجاون دائما الى بديل اخر والدراسه
الصادمه راويه ان منظمه الصحه العالميه
قالت ان المواطن الاردني يصرف على التدخين
اكثر ما يصرفه على الطعام والشراب ورمان
الدواء يعني المواطن الاردني الشخص في
العائله الواحده يصرف ما قيمته 150 دولار
شهريا على التدخين هذه الازمه هي ازمه
اقتصاديه ولكن يعني الاردن او المواطن
الاردني يذهب بشركات التدخين او ربما
الحكومه التي دائما وميرارا وتكرارا برفع
الضريبه على الدخان وهو بالنسبه للاردنيين
امسى اساسيات وليس كماليات ان تذهب لرفع
اسعار اخرى لان هذه عاده متاصله بالشعب
الاردني ربما التدخين ربما للضغوطه
اقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والماليه يذهب
المجتمع الاردني للتدخين وايضا هناك دراسه
تقول ان 10% من رفع اسعار الدخان قد يؤدي
الى نزول او التخلي على الدخان او تخفيف
اعداد
ربما هي ليست مقارنه جيده ولكن هي تساعد
في تركه شكرا جزيلا سهى جميل مراسله صباح
العربيه من عمان لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات